espania komui comentado pues vas yep
Teresa quoted a quintanilla hoffentlich
hidden meet Laval a sea cliff does he
know Hakeem and some kid we agreed we
face a problem thats a European problem
and not a great one our internal
decisions make our external action
stronger or weaker so I expect member
states today to take responsibility at
least Astarte Dozo Dozo concessions kiss
FM italia eloquence a doula
responsibility party jay carlin some TP
to renew repair Devon and Clovis the
canvas on and Clarence I plans
originally hot spots under 9 h-c special
avenues Mahan isthmus v dandy unfertile
on definite Ida's mid concreting exactly
and onto a flick of an affine bang Eva
Ezekiel here comes Linda it is necessary
to create a new approach in Europe and
that is based on effective reception
centers and then those in either
protection to be relocated with the
Solidarity of all other European states
punish not everybody is on board however
I'd remind you once again that the
European Union even this evening is
capable with a qualified majority of
making a decision we agreed on the
40,000 everybody was on board on that so
I think that we can now already begin as
of tomorrow the day after tomorrow with
the medication of the 40,000 it's the
second Commission proposal to relocate a
hundred and twenty thousand persons and
although we're looking at an emergency
procedures must be respected if you so
it was too early for a decision to be
taken today this is you we need to find
a way to combine our collective
responsibility before our conscience and
before the law to make sure that people
who deserve Asylum because they are
refugees get asylum in Europe our
response
to the refugee crisis a crisis that
unfortunately we last as long as our
neighborhood is on fire will shape our
history